قلا المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن يعتقد انه يجب
على الولايات المتحده بيع تركيا مقاتلات
اف 16 لتحديث اسطورها الحليب وقد وصف وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه علاقه بلاده بتركيا
بانها علاقه شراكه قويه
انا الولايات المتحده وتركيا معا في
ايطاليا عدد من القضايا انطلاقا من كونهما
حليفيين
بدوره شدد وزير الخارج
مع الولايات المتحده في محاربه الارهاب
وتعزيز التعاون بما يشكل تهديدا لتنظيم
الدوله وحزب العمال الكردستاني
على صفقه مقاتلات اف 16 لما يتماشى ومصالح
الدولتين الاستراتيجيه
وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه على لسان
المتحدث باسم انيسبريس ان اداره الرئيس جو
بايدن ابلغت الكونجرس تاييدها بيع طائره
اف 16 لتركيا وان الاتصالات جاريه مع
المشرعين الامريكيين في هذا الشاب
للتعامل مع التهديدات الامنيه التي
تواجهها
مع شركائنا
مع الكونجرس 2016
للتعامل مع المخاوف الامنيه الحقيقيه التي
تواجهها
من الخارجيه الامريكيه مراسلنا محمد
الاحمد اذا طائرات اف 16 لتركيا الان
فعليا كيف تستقبل الولايات المتحده هذا
الخبر الذي ربما في السابق لم يكن ليحصل
هكذا
قبل قليل فقط صدر بيان مشترك عقب اللقاء
الذي جرى اليوم بين وزير الخارجيه
الولايات المتحده وتركيا وكان هناك تاكيد
على تعزيز تعاون والشراكه العسكريه بين
الجانبين بما في ذلك خطط تحديث اسطول
تركيا من مقاتلات الاف 16 بالرغم من عدم
ذكر البيان ل- اا الصفقه بشكل محدد الصفقه
التي يتم الحديث عنها المتعلقه بتقديم
الولايات المتحده او بيع الولايات المتحده
لحوالي 40 مقاتله من طراز الاف 16 لتركيا
بقيمه 20 مليار دولار وهي الصفقه التي ان
تمت ستكون واحده من اكبر الصفقات التي
تعقدها الولايات المتحده مع دوله اجنبيه
خلال السنوات القليله الماضيه كان هناك
ايضا تاكيد في هذا البيان المشترك على دعم
وحده وسلامه الاراضي الاوكرانيه ود حل
سياسي لانهاء هذا الحرب لانهاء الحرب
الروسيه المستمره على
اوكرانيا وكذلك تم مناقشه جميع
ابعاد الصراع الروسي سواء من الناحيه
الميدانيه او من الناحيه السياسيه لكن في
الواقع هذه الزياره زياره وزير الخارجيه
التركي الى الولايات المتحده
تركز بشكل كبير على صفقه مقاتلات الاف 16
والتي تحتاجها تركيا بقوه لتحديد اسطولها
الجوي خاصه بعد اقصائها من برنامج مقاتلات
الاف خمسه وثلاثين عقب اعلانها عن حيازه
منظومه الاس 400 من الجانب الروسي وهو ما
ردت عليه الولايات المتحده باقصاء تركيا
من برنامج الاف 53 لكنها في الوقت نفسه
وفي هذه الخطوه المتوقعه تعزي الشركتها مع
تركيا من خلال هذه الصفقه بالرغم من وجود
بعض الاعتراضات عليها في الكونجرس من قبل
المشرقين خاصه بوب مارندي اسرائيل لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ الذي
هدد بوقتها لم تغير ان ترى من سياساتها
لكن يعتقد على نطاق واسع لان الاداره
الامريكيه التي اعرب المتحدث باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه قبل قليل عن دعمها
لهذه الصفقه يعتقد على نطاق واسع انها
مرتبطه ايضا بموافقه تركيا وتسريعها
لعمليه انضمام كل من فنلندا والسويد الى
حلف شمال الاطلسي النيتو ومسؤولون
امريكيون كانوا قد ذكروا لصحيفه الوصل
جورنال بان موافقه الكونغرس وتخطي عقبات
الكونغرس للتمرير هذه الصفقه ستكون بدورها
مرتبطه بموافقه تركيا على تسريع انضمام كل
من فنلندا والسويد الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
النيتو بالرغم من امتناع تركيا لحد الان
عن هذه الخطوه بسبب اتهاماتها لكل من
البلدين بصلاتها مع الفصائل الكرديه
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن زياره مهمه في
توقيت مهم
تلقين بطلالها على مجموعه من القضايا سواء
ان الثنائيه وايضا الاقليميه
وهمم اوكرانيا
بيان وزاره الخارجيه التركيه في هذا
الخصوص شكرا جزيلا لك من الخارجيه
الامريكيه مراسل جزيره محمد